le vendredi près pas
mais pré halloween bonjour fois bonjour
j'ai tous vêtus des couleurs des
feuilles mortes de l'halloween
félicitations ce n'est pas de c'était
pas qu'on s'est mis d'accord
chantal bonjour bonjour stéphane paloma
bonjour jeu samir bonjour et puis grâce
à cette personne
marie-claude nous sommes maintenant au
nom à travers le monde et je vous dis
qu'est la règle des problèmes marie
claude a alors on a deux invités
aujourd'hui sur skype n'a pas le temps
de rigoler mais on va quand même le
faire parce que c'est la formule de
l'émission avec nos jeux évidemment nos
jeux favoris
1 quelle vous gagnez la couronne de
l'initiant à travers de jeux ou trois
jeux la couronne elle se trouve
présentement depuis trois semaines sur
la traite de chanteurs non non non j'ai
été détrôné la semaine dernière c'est
vrai j'oubliais on à la troisième fois
la prend avec à la maison c'est ça
m'apporte quelque chose
alors écoutez rapprocher un peu des
collègues il a besoin
c'est une équipe soudée avec ça
j'aime le mot équipe pas section nous on
parle de section des trémies week est
peut-être oui équipe c'est plus
convivial
alors équipe quel est le sujet démission
aujourd'hui vidéo 5 images le premier
qui pense avoir trouvé la réponse
s'exprime ouvertement ses les médias
après tout on peut s'exprimer ici on
parle la vidéo comme on peut sa voix la
liberté d'opinion la version à travers
bissao du canada vous avez tous raison
mais pas l'homme elle brûle plus que oui
j'ai dit liberté de presse le
rapprochement ils s'affairent entre les
deux hommes la relation de ce états unis
avec leurs habitants
et la liberté ouais en est question est
il si un peu plus que ça c'est un peu
plus il y avait un fils en une intuition
j'avais il ya deux jours déjà
lorsqu'il ya eu ces attentats aux états
unis où ses tentatives de on a déposé
des bombes et on accuse la presse où
l'on l'accusé ouvertement où on l'accuse
si l'ancien jeu vidéo numéro deux va
maintenant vous montrez vraiment c'est
un travail ici qu'ont effectué au cours
de la semaine pour déterminer le thème
et ça c'est la firme ihs au cours de la
semaine au ce matin c'est devenu ceci
regarder très simple avec le titre c'est
sans équivoque 0 mensonge qu'est ce que
ben voilà c'est un petit montage vidéo
qu'on a fait des petites mains comme ça
qui vous montre l'actualité et
manipulation des médias et mensonges des
petites mains politique mais en fait ce
que monsieur tron pas dit c'est que les
médias étaient à blâmer en ce qui
concerne la guerre les tensions sociales
aux états unis les led oui le point de
vue rejoint ce qu'ils disent est depuis
toujours avec nous deux oui il n'y a
rien de nouveau
il fait que réitérer sa pensée par
rapport aux médias est un désir commence
à s'arrêter
ça atteint des sommets un peu un peu
inquiétant vous n'êtes pas surpris
vous n'êtes donc pas surpris non j'ai
pas de surprise connaissant l'homme
c'est sa réaction à un moment j'ai un
personnage que la presse a apprivoisé
est ce qu'il est en train de changer la
conduite des choses dans le monde
d'influencer les comportements qu'on
peut avoir par rapport aux médias c'est
la question
je ne suis pas contre les
questionnements je crois qu'on doit
questionner ce qu'on voit souvent en
fait on questionne pas assez
probablement ce qu'on reçoit comme
information il y avait beaucoup de
vidéos qui circulent de façon virale
dans les médias sociaux
et souvent on a tendance à prendre ça
pour acquis a qu à se dire que c'est la
vérité infuse et puis je crois qu'on
doit questionner je suis d'accord avec
cette possibilité d'aider des
questionnés c'est un droit aussi des
questionnés cependant quand les sources
quelle information est vérifiée et
véritable voilà la vidéo no 3 qui a fait
le tour du monde c'est peut-être la
vidéo de la semaine où vous voyez 30
pour le faut je pense qu'on va éviter de
l'entendre cette fois ci mais on vend
moins vous le montrer qui est en train
de faire un discours c'était à ohis
concert un discours partisan ou devant
ses partisans retenus pour prendre un
discours partisan là et il a dit il faut
que le cnn les médias voilà ce qu'il dit
responsabilité de mettre fin à
l'hostilité sans fin il ose attaquer aux
histoires négatives souvent fausses le
jour même
des colis alors qu'il avait un message
lors d'une rencontre à la maison d'arrêt
faut être fou et solidaire fruits
puisqu'après il va à l'attaqué alors
c'est moi je vais à venir la
conversation et spécialiste en quelques
instants mais j'aimerais vous entendre
plus là dessus
en fait quand je les dis tantôt c'est un
personnage qu'on a apprivoisé au fil au
fil du temps donc je suis pas très très
surprise par ces multiples réactions
c'est bourré de contradictions
malheureusement on est obligés de
composer avec c'est un président qui dit
une chose le matin l'après-midi quelques
secondes même après il se contredit donc
c'est à penser que son équipe de
communication est totalement déconnectée
du personnage
et que penser de l'équipe de
communication du prince héritier
d'arabie saoudite parce que à chaque
jour l'histoire a changé
tout dépend des pressions qui sont là et
on nous sort une version une valise
avait il avait pour au début il s'est
rien passé et puis après ils ont reconnu
15 s'est passé quelque chose et puis à
chaque chercheur chargé mais maintenant
je voudrais revenir à monsieur trempe si
on peut dire donc trempée et quelque
part il est en train de suivre aussi
dans l'opinion publique il ya un
questionnement comme disait parlement
sur la façon de fonctionner des médias
si alors je vais faire un peu l'avocat
de ma boîte si tout le monde
fonctionnait comme radio canada où on
avait c'est quoi les normes de travail
de fonctionnement des journalistes et
qui sont claires c'est et il ya plus de
transparence plus être que les gens
iraient irait moins croirait plus là les
journalistes autre chose le problème
chez le public sait que il va vers la
foule
ils vont partager les gens vont partager
sans faire le minimum de il ya même pas
un minimum de questionnements dès que je
vois quelque chose surtout si ça rejoint
mes convictions sur tout ça renforce mes
préjugés home & production
là je vais partager je pense qu'il y a
un peu de la part du jeune âge de
montrer un peu plus de transparence
comment est-ce qu'on travaille par
exemple si je fais je ne détiens pas la
vérité absolue moi je dit
j'expose des faits je vais chercher je
raconte pas sans vérifier si les gens
comprennent comment je fonctionne
peut-être que la confiance établie
et peut-être qu'à ce moment là quand
monsieur trompe annonça les gens vont
dire oui c'est qu'il faut vraiment il
faut vraiment faire attention récemment
à dans la section est une américaine on
a vécu quelque chose qui nous a vraiment
surpris on était confronté aux fausses
nouvelles directement
il y à des sites internet qui imitent
des sites internet officiels des
compagnies de nouvelles des compagnies
de presse dix agences de presse m
il y avait un site une page sur facebook
qui était la copie conforme
qu'est-ce mains d'une page d'un journal
mexicain et prenait les mêmes logo les
mêmes manières de fonctionner sauf que
il s'est inventé des nouvelles et puis
et on est et on était nous pris avec ça
parce qu'ils nous une cité is it et
radio canada is it est un journaliste de
radio canada international
il y avait une il avait le journaliste
qui écrivait cette nouvelle signée avec
à commercial et recel et n'être point
c'est à donkey fait c'est tout tu as lu
tion un travail que nous on a jamais
produit et qu'on n'avait pas vérifié
donc il faut vraiment faire attention à
ce qu'on voit et la seule différence
entre le site original et les sites qui
mitent est celui-là qui copiait
s'étaient unis parce que sa 10è point m
et aix ou point m
le hic si c'est lui qui faisait c'était
juste c'est vraiment il faut faire après
ça qu'on a invité spécial qui nous
attend il est très patient on n'y va pas
tout de suite ont une minute pour
répandre le premier jeu de l'ajout de la
grosse boule cette semaine les choses
changent on a des médias comme je
l'exercé in aussi des grands médias
comme le washington post
sans lesquels la vérité serait tout
autre l'adisq selon le washington post
entre le jour de son inauguration est le
premier ou dernier donald trump a fait
combien de déclarations publiques
fausses ou induisant à l'erreur combien
en l'espace de cinq cents quelques jours
lui trois fois par jour
on va aller à 558 joue à trois fois par
jour ça fait combien ça
je vais je vais un peu mon derrière ce
1500 mais pas toutes ces déclarations
sont fausses annonces alain bazire est
pour induisent en erreur
28 plus déclaration par jour de fausses
nouvelles ou de déclaration qui n'avait
pas révélé efficace demandes par jour ou
par heure par jour que ça sent le
premier ou dernier et le moment de son
inauguration 550 jours voilà 10 22 22
fautes
c'est beaucoup trop peu de mon point de
vue moi j'irai avec une centaine
seulement
c'est bien je dirais à 180 annoncé 80
fausse des 80 cents 480 d'accord donc eu
un atout d'être là tous les quatre jours
4 d'accord je dirais 90 90 alors qui a
dit 180 mois vous êtes le plus proche de
la bonne réponse et c'est la bonne
réponse c'est 7,6 mensonge par jour mike
et ça correspond à 4229 régulation
fausses ou trompeuses
c'est le washington post que ça va
garder ça je vous donne une cité fausses
déclarations
ouais on va aller vers notre invité
spécial le premier aujourd'hui il s'agit
de ferry de kerchove qui est de la
faculté des sciences sociales l'école
supérieure d'affaires publiques et
internationales mais il faut dire
monsieur l'ambassadeur bonjour bonjour
bonjour bonjour comme le radio canada
international jamais tout à fait à la
fine pointe de l'information je vous
signale qu'on vient d'arrêter quelqu'un
dans le contexte des fameux oui j'ai vu
pour ce qui est de votre évaluation du
nombre de mentions de jam c'est vraiment
vous ne suivez pas les nouvelles ça fait
longtemps qu'il a passé le cap de 5000
quel est votre source généralement bien
informée comme on dit dans les milieux
diplomatiques
mais c'est bien vous êtes mieux
connectés que nous à la réalité semble
t-il écoutez on vous invite parce que
vous avez été ambassadeur moyen orient
est évidemment parce que vous êtes
le loup nous on va avoir le gros plan
canadien pas le gros plan américain le
gros plan canadien sur ce qui se passe
là bas les relations entre donald trump
et le prince héritier
oh ça n'étonnerait personne parce que
depuis des générations les présidents
américains se contente d'une certaine
manière par rapport à cet allié très
important il ya aussi la relation
maintenant tendues entre le canada et
l'arabie saoudite
donc il ne s'est pas du tout le même
gentillesse entre les ça fonctionne pas
très bien actuellement
c'est pas le même grand amour voilà
parlons de ce que le canada et 7
négocier ou comment ils essaient de s'en
sortir
moi j'ai l'impression dans toutes ces
histoires que on aime on se sent moins
seul au canada au niveau de la
diplomatie canadienne
depuis que cette histoire a éclaté en
arabie saoudite du meurtre du
journaliste parce que on était ensemble
et c'est là où moi d'où les seuls à se
dire mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
un régime qui nous envoie promener
j'avoue que le tweet de madame fui
l'inde à l'époque avait l'air tout à
fait dans l'espace et maintenant il est
revenu dans la réalité la plus claire
effectivement maintenant nous faisons
partie de ceux qui font qu'ils ont un
rôle à jouer dans le contexte de cette
affaire
le seul problème c'est que notre affaire
est plus compliqué donné qu'on parle de
ce fameux contrat de 15 milliards de
dollars dans l'est dans l'est ontarien
qui en a grand besoin et c'était une des
grandes raisons pour lequel le
gouvernement canadien actuel s'était
servi d'une vague signature de l'époque
de monsieur harper pour redire que les
dés sont cuits nous devons accepter ce
contrat est alors maintenant la question
c'est est ce que véritablement on va
priver l'est de l'ontario du de la
continuation de ce marché qui a déjà été
d'ailleurs réduit par les saoudiens eux
mêmes parce que il ya les saoudiens
ayant subi au fond un certain déficit
ont décidé de réduire le nombre de
petites gip de petit j vous souhaiter
céder petit gym
je pourrais vous parler longuement de
ses jeeps là parce que je suis très
jaloux de cjp là dans la mesure où ils
ont un canon qui rit qui est capable
avec 90 milles est d'envoyer un obus à 4
à 10 km de la jeep
moi quand j'étais là une quand j'avais
un peloton de charges avaient le même au
but montirat un kilo mais donc ça c'est
ma jalousie personnel
tout ça pour dire que la possibilité de
suspendre ce contrat est quelque chose
dont monsieur trudeau parle il évoque
surtout le coup terrible que ce qu'il
qu'on pourrait devoir payer dans un
arbitrage mais si vous voulez la vraie
question c'est est ce que le canada dans
le contexte actuel doit être en avant
pointe de gens de mesures de rétorsion
ou au contraire de simplement de
surseoir de moratoire ou compte tenu de
l'importance relativement limitée que
nous avons en dans le contexte des
relations saoudienne canadienne mais
dans le dans le contexte aussi d'un
contrat très important
pourquoi serions nous plus plus plus
chrétiens que le pape est pourquoi
irions nous de l'avant dès maintenant
alors vous allez me dire que je ne
réponds pas aux aspirations de nos amis
ou au npd qui disent qu'il faut
absolument annuler ce contrat
je crois que monsieur trudeau jongle il
remet d'ailleurs habilement évidemment
le contrat sur le dow de monsieur harper
on finira par se rappeler que monsieur
harper a été notre premier ministre
mais la vraie question c'est est ce que
nous devons être en avant point tout ce
que nous devrions pas attendre
simplement que les choses c'est cool que
nous obtenions plus de renseignements
sur la façon dont la fère s'est déroulé
et est ce qu'à un moment donné la vraie
question c'est la succession est ce qu
on pourrait même croire que mbs mohammed
bin salman va rester au pouvoir
parce que vous allez il n'y a au fond
que les russes et les chinois qui
acceptent l'explication de mohamed bin
salman que même april enfin les russes
tout à l'heure on dit écoutez si un
communiqué royal dit que là le roi et le
prince héritier n'ont rien à voir là
dedans pourquoi est-ce que nous
contesterions ça parce que ça c'est tout
à fait typique de chez nos amis russes
mais véritablement ya deux questions qui
se posent un
à quelle vitesse nous canadiens allons
nous mettre en marche une une suspension
ou une résiliation de contrat je crois
que nous sommes très loin du camp et
deuxièmement à quel moment les états
unis qui joue
un peu sur les deux tableaux vont aller
d'un côté c'est à dire exonéré
complètement mbs même si on trouve le
corps les résidus du corps dans le fond
du puits dans la résidence du consul
général
ou alors de véritablement dans le
contexte des primaires qui sont dans dix
jours
est ce que monsieur tron va vouloir
jouer un jeu différent pour augmenter
les chances 2-2 républicaine gagné donc
cibler ce qui est terrible dans ces
affaires là c'est que la faire elle-même
ne compte plus pour rien c'est tout le
monde politique tout les tractations
tous les soupeser et c'est ça et même
pour notre gouvernement nous parce que
vous dites de pour pisser sur le côté
canadien
il est clair que pour le gouvernement
canadien c'est de jongler avec la faire
jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait finalement un
moment décisif et je crois que mon des
civils n'est pas encore là et je
comprends parfaitement politiquement le
premier ministe de jongler dans cette
affaire et de parler d'une suspension
éventuelle mais les allemands eux
parlent de moratoire et les allemands
beaucoup plus à perdre que nous une
autre question
je vais rebondir par rapport à ce que
vous dites vous dites que le
gouvernement a tendance à jongler par
rapport à cette affaire
je vais vous empruntez le terme jongler
pensez vous qu'il jongle également
monsieur trudeau lorsqu'il dit qu'il va
suspendre disons le permis
d'exploitation ce qui a trait aux
prochaines livraisons à quoi ça sert de
réviser ce permis là alors qu'on va
relancer les exportations bientôt est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une autre
façon de jongler alors autrement dit ce
que ce vous dire c'est que tout à coup
vous trouvez dans le règlement sur les
permis à l'exportation qui lie à une
clause que nous n'avons pas mis en
vigueur et que maintenant on le met en
vigueur parce que tout à coup le régime
de deviendra encore plus affreux parce
qu'il a fait abattre un journaliste je
sais qu'on peut toujours interprété un
règlement comme on le veut mais c'est
assez amusant d'essayer de retrouver un
permis à l'exportation sont changer la
donne
plutôt que de simplement dire est que
telle affaire est affreux nous ne
voulons plus gérer avec ce pays il a
terminé mais est-ce que sur le plan
judel égal est-ce que sur le plan
juridique
l'invocation d'une d'une interprétation
puis rigoureuse et permis à les portes
l'exportation permet d'éviter nappe
na li té qui serait donnée dans le cause
du fameux milliards que le premier
ministre a évoqué dans la dent lors de
la dernière intervention est ce qu'une
question une autre question iranienne
j'ai pas de réponse depuis que je suis
cette affaire elle est le jeu que
jouèrent guyane en turquie le président
absolument merveilleux n'oubliez pas
qu'il ya une rivalité quand même assez
profonde entre le leader le leader
religieux des sunnites et lors l'ancien
le nouvel empereur de l' empire ottoman
qui veut reconquérir si vous voulez
cette espèce d'autorité global sur le
monde musulman et c'est véritablement
une aspiration clair chez lui alors lui
il tient y tient le roi salman par la
barbichette et en disant si tu ne livre
pas davantage d'informations moi je vais
commencer à sortir les enregistrements
que j'ai dans mes petits papiers
pour l'instant ils le jouent très
habilement parce qu'il veut quand même
rétablir sa son autorité dans la région
il est un petit peu battue en brèche
soudain sous la coupe des russes
il veut montrer qu'il est un des grands
leaders et que les choses passent par
lui
alors alors c'est vraiment un jeu habile
c'est un jeu qui relève de la stratégie
ardoines ce fou comme du tiers comme du
quart du sort de monsieur khashoggi ça
ça n'a absolument rien à voir mais il
s'en sert habilement pour montrer que
lui aussi il tient ça entre les mains je
crois que c'est très habile mais tout ça
et veut le vilain est affreux et les
chantal dernier occasion oui j'ai posé
une question par rapport à l'incidence
géopolitique et même jour stratégique
dans la sous région
pensez vous que ce soit une stratégie
gagnante pour le président turc de
chercher à se positionner comme leader
dans cette sous-région là vous avez
c'est très intéressant de demander qui
est gagnant qui est perdant dans une
région qui passe son temps être
perturbés d'une fois à l'autre on peut
monter on peut descendre
je crois que dans le contexte de la
volonté à long terme stratégique des
rohan il risque de perdre à plus long
terme parce que finalement une fois que
la crise sera passée le leadership quand
même des lieux saints restent au moins
ou des saoudiens et qu'il pourrait y
avoir tout à coup une revanche du
berceau sur cette affaire là alors à
court terme ça al'air stratégiquement
solide à long terme vous avez tout à
fait raison de poser la question
il va y avoir des tas de plume qui vont
être perdus dans cette affaire là ce qui
me désole c'est que le seul qui en
sortira gagnant c'est quand même 30
l'attraction ça me par rapport à ça et
on voit que l'iran est un peu comme dans
cette affaire que vous avez un
commentaire sur ça les iraniens sont
beaucoup plus subtil beaucoup plus vite
et aux ivresses beaucoup plus au long
terme
ils voient ça ils vieillissent tient
plus depuis six bagarre puis se noue ne
feront absolument qu aucun commentaire
pourquoi parce que à long terme nous y
gagnons plus et us plus ces pays
s'affaiblissent plus on commence à faire
ressortir dans le même contexte
l'horreur de la guerre du yémen et tout
ça plus on va peut-être se rendre compte
à l'occident que cette espèce de
équivalence morale que dans l'occident
n'a donc par exemple dans le contexte du
conflit et mène c'est en fait une
fiction totale les je ne dis pas que les
iraniens ne font pas du demain dans la
région mais qui ce qui est en train de
démolir le yémen c'est les saoudiens
donc ciblé pour les iraniens cette
grande discrétion qui est tout à fait
dans la nature de leur régime
je les admire pour le faire mais il faut
dire que j'ai peut-être un petit fait
pour lire and l''iran l'iran parce que
c'était mon premier post écoutez c'est
dommage qu'on puisse pas vous envoyer
les blindés sont habillement ping j
blindés pour moi on va négocier
signature ya pas trop pas de problème de
budget ici écoutez ferry merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé aux faits vie alors
c'était prochaine monsieur l'ambassadeur
ferry de kerchove faculté des sciences
sociales à l'école si la sphère publique
internationale émissions continuent à
débouler maintenant avec notre deuxième
de la grosse boule il a gagné 20 points
maintenant mise en jeu de 30 points
on peut tu j'ajuste et d'éclairage
passerait rien à faire
leur défaite alors deuxième manche ça va
être assez drôle d'aller voir mohamed
bin salman ou donald trump en garde les
deux ensemble aujourd'hui au fameux duo
politique qui est à la tête de la plus
grosse fortune personnelle selon vous
50% de chance d'avoir la bonne réponse
vous dit qu'on les donne les points
aujourd'hui
alors ouais mais tu donnes seulement ou
donald trump qui est à la tête de la
plus grosse fortune personnelle à donald
trump mois m d'une semaine ben salman
ben ça va le pétrolier c'est le
pétrolier de trente deux 32 200
héritiers parce que ses personnages à la
nuance mais oui dans ces pays là le
pétrole appartient tous les deux vous
hérité de la couronne pour moment 30
points si les chiffres magazine 17
milliards de dollars pour ce qui est du
prince héritier et selon 3,1 milliards
de dollars
c'est un minable pardon c'est un tout
petit minet minus c'est ça que moi
j'essaie vous aviez beaucoup de choses à
faire et 5 milliards pour le prince 3,1
milliards da durant la campagne
électorale parce que le groupe se
présentait comme étant un
multimilliardaire final son accord de
partir de trois tumulte et voûté on est
prêts pour notre eau très vite et on va
donner le ton à la technique de réagir
oui mais parce qu'il allait demander à
monsieur l'ambassadeur c'est parce que
les poids économique la force que cette
famille de l'arabie saoudite a en ce
moment est vraiment tres est très grande
sont très forts cette rentrée c'est très
important dans la région aussi dans que
oui trompe et nous on est prêts des
états unis puis on voit ça mais là bas
c'est une autre paire de manches alors
notre prochain éviter espère qu'on va
pouvoir établir un contact il est
justement un spécialiste du moyen-orient
et sa petite famille un sol qui est elle
vous le connaissez
erste d'ottawa de non non non on
n'espère si je reviens de samir on
connaît sa pire ça on a toujours le
numéro de téléphone s'il devait y avoir
c'est marie-claude devrait entendre le
son ça c'est la cuisine de l'émission
avant qu'elle commence avant onze là
vous voyez à quoi ça ressemble encore
meilleur quand les caméras ne tournent à
marie-claude mais il est passé en ligne
c'est ça que j'ai vu c'est juste qu'il
est en train de redémarrer
voici monsieur sol passé la meilleure
j'ai pu trouver mais on s'occupe pas ça
mais je vais peut-être essayé de
l'appeler au tel y'a peut-être d'aider
d'autres questions oui le troisième jeu
de la grosse boule mari elle a déjà 0
dans la lah on peut attendre
bah oui on peut attaquer ce que vous
êtes capable de partir une vidéo sur un
ton ordinateur parce que j'ai une vidéo
qui a vous montrez vous savez comment ça
y est tu pars pas la bonne en pleine
émission pour éviter toute catastrophe
je préfère qu'on attend du notw et vous
avez raison donc en jeu au jeu à la
grosse boule 6 50 points cette fois ci
ah la la
à l'occasion de la visite du prince
héritier saoudien aux états unis
le président a présenté la presse par
deux mois on accent mais pas à présenter
à la presse de contrats d'armes et de
matériel de défense entre les deux pays
alors il a apporté une grosse carte
elle aurait voulu me montrer les vidéos
mais ça a été fini par une une compagnie
enfin non une agence de com ou deux
comme kiné une compétition alors on peut
pas présenter ça mais il ya montré de
grosses cartes en disant voici à quoi ça
ressemble nous échangeons jascha news
connue aux etats-unis nous allons vendre
chez vous c'était combien de milliards
de dollars
combien de milliards de 217,7 samedi à
non non non c'était 100 mille ans je
mettrai ça je mettrai 5 milliards très
bien 100 milliards de dollars que les
états unis d'en avant en armement et un
blindé toutes sortes qui dit mieux
chaque année vous
- c'est chaque année total pour les
prochaines années les contrats quand
ismaël lô les contre dix ans on dit ça
vous précisez 510 pour les 20 prochaines
années
les quinze prochains sans aucune
importance qui a été signé a été dit
quand il est venu les princes héritiers
quand il est allé à washington le prince
héritier et ethier a parlé de plusieurs
contrats à quoi bon ya pas de
chronogramme pour cette livraison non
bah il y en a peut-être là mais dans 10
15 le plaisir des livraisons à l'infini
non mais ça sur les deux contrats qui
ont été signés quand il est venu me suis
salle et au téléphone jean sol vous nous
entendez bien répondent les filles et
mal parce qu'il ya du bruit dans
l'arrière fond d'accord écouté pendant
que vous ajustez vos l'écoutent
nous on répond à la question des jarrets
près du mal à répondre à cette question
parce qu'elle n'est pas assez précise et
autour enfin je sais pas c'est dans les
trente prochaines années les 30
prochaines semaines le canada les 100
prochaines années
j'irai au tour de 150 milliards 150
hyaric les contrats présentement signé
par les états unis pour d'envoyer des
armes très vite vous dites 150 milliards
c'est dans dix ans ou dans quelle époque
ça pourrait dans 60 ans la sq ont
instillé comme ça si aujourd'hui en ce
moment même alors paloma de sa 200
milliards de dollars vous avez tous tort
nous dit pas c'est satan et écoutez
c'est vraiment pas cette ça ça m'a
surpris moi je serais très surpris je
connais la bonne réponse où elle est là
écoutez c'est pas où tu sais pas autant
vous pensé ces 12,5 milliards seulement
là seulement face au canada on est dans
les 15 milliards qu'est-ce qui va signer
quand il est à dire
30 quand il est agréable sauf s'il est
vraiment les détails ses 12 500 truies
38 milliards 3 le prochain budget le
plus proche non vous êtes le maire mais
ce seul bronze au 50 vous gagnez oui oui
il ya beaucoup de bavarder beaucoup de
bruit des gens qui parlent en même temps
au long de toute notre attention et pour
vous mettre en avant par yeom un coup
[ __ ] martinez à la première question
pour vous profession vous avez une
question sur comment s'organise la
géopolitique au moyen orient
c'est vrai en fait je voulais savoir on
parlait tout à l'heure de la dé la
richesse des preuves concernant 1 en
comparaison à celles du prince héritier
de l'arabie saoudite
donc on disait le poids à l'importance
que la famille actuellement au pouvoir
en arabie saoudite a dans la région
comment pourrais la décrire bon l'arabie
saoudite c'est une sorte de pays qui
appartient à une famille la famille des
saoud qui est richissime pour des
raisons que l'on sait des réserves
pétrolières énorme d une main de pétro
dollars cumulés depuis quelques
décennies et une volonté de répandre
aussi son influence à travers le
wahhabisme dans le monde arabe dans le
monde musulman
en général donc c'est une c'est un pays
en particulier près contrôlé par une
famille composée de plusieurs milliers
de pages qui vers le pays comme on gère
son budget personnel et puis par rapport
aux autres pays autour
êtes vous diriez que elle a une grande
influence cette famille aussi oui parce
que c'est un pays très riche par rapport
à ses voisins qui sont ils peuvent aussi
être des pays pétroliers mais qui sont
plus petits comme le koweït le qatar etc
alors effectivement c'est une c'est un
pays important dans la dans la région
importante d'abord par sa richesse comme
chez dim est important aussi par la
relation avec les états unis
faut comprendre et l'arabie saoudite
mais rien sans les états unis d'arabie
saoudite dépend de la de la relation
mister géopolitiques économiques avec
les états unis
les etats-unis ont besoin d'arabie
saoudite comme socle de leur influence
dans la région
avec son les deux pays sur lesquels
arvisais s'est dit d'avis s'appuient
alors leurs minots dit est important
pour elle même mais est importante aussi
comme extension comme prolongement de la
delà de la flotte américaine dans la
région
elle et l'acteur premier de la politique
américaine dans la région avec israël
naturellement et ces trois-là essaie
d'organiser une audience une coalition
anti iranienne donc l'arabie saoudite
joue un rôle à la fois économique mais
aussi politique et militaire dans la
région
n'oublions pas non plus l'affluence de
l'arabie saoudite sur le plan économique
mondiale elle peut réguler les prix
pétroliers par l'augmentation ou la
baisse de la production et et le pétrole
et le soutien du dollar américain
le pétrole et le le est le garant les
cas remplacer leur par rapport par
rapport à la halla halla à la sécurité
ou à la garantie du dollar américain
donc un pays très important des régions
plus important naturellement que ses
voisins pour les raisons que
merci monsieur seulement j'ai une
question par rapport au petit état du
qatar je sais que c'est pas l'objet de
longues discussions mais qu'est ce que
c'est quoi son poids dans la région en
ce moment le qatar est un tout petit
pays qui est devenu important à cause
des découvertes de gaz
récemment il est un des pays les gaziers
principaux du monde aujourd'hui
alors il a à cause de cette richesse
d'ailleurs il s'est découvert quelques
intérêts stratégiques dans la région
il était un des pays qui sont intervenus
les premiers dans la guerre en syrie
pour appuyer les djihadistes et c'est
trouvait alors dans une que je suis
assez assez cocasse parce qu'il n'a pas
l'affluence n'a pas les moyens de sa
politique
il est aussi un pays qui en présente un
autre courant de la de l'islamisme c'est
le courant des frères musulmans les
l'arabie saoudite représente au
wahhabisme est un autre courant ces deux
courants sont arrivés alors le qatar est
devenu une bête noire pour l'arabie
saoudite qui a essayé de me lasser
l'année dernière par une note un embargo
des menaces militaires des raisons
géostratégiques mais aussi à raison
idéologique du à cette rivalité entre
deux courants delà de la musique la vie
celle des frères musulmans pour le qatar
et l'arabie saoudite clos habitants avec
le qatar c'est que le qatar est
maintenant associé au à la turquie la
turquie d'erdogan et est un pays dirigé
par un président associé aux frères
musulmans
donc on a ici coalition frères musulmans
en turquie et au qatar contre le
wahhabisme saoudien
et c'est là où on voit là l on peut
comprendre un peu mieux ce qui était
rare à joly qui s'était associé aux
frères musulmans et a été assassiné pour
par le prince héritier ou par l'arabie
saoudite qui représente un autre courant
donc la rivalité du rivalités
géopolitiques entre le qatar et l'arabie
saoudite
et maintenant le qatar et la turquie et
l'arabie saoudite
mais c'est aussi la rivalité idéologique
au sein de l'islamisme au sein du goût
du grand courant est stable
fantastique question s'améliorer puis et
chantal oui comment réagissez vous à
cette forme d'hypocrisie qui
caractérisent généralement les relations
internationales
parce que on a tendance à assister à une
espèce de deux poids deux mesures dans
les relations entre l'occident et
certains pays de cette région du golfe
regardez les états unis sont souvent une
tendance à sortir leur relation de
conditions spécifiques sur le plan
politique par exemple je veux parler de
la démocratie et du respect des droits
de l'homme
mais généralement la turquie aux biens
d'iran ne vont pas être traités de la
même façon que l'arabie saoudite
donc comment réagissez vous à cela
combien moulinois c'est justement ce que
ce meurtre de kashmiri est en train de
mettre en lumière et la contradiction
entre le la rhétorique généreuse
moralisante qu'on entend de la part des
diplomaties occidentales et les réalités
à savoir des relations de rapports de
force et d'impunité accordée aux alliés
des pays occidentaux
je me disais si l'iran ou la russie
avait touché à un cheveu d'une personne
comme crash aubry on aura une cascade de
sanctions le meurtre de khashoggi arabie
saoudite ne provoque du côté occidental
des situations de gênes et d'embarras
car on aurait voulu que ce que ne pas
entendre parler
on aurait voulu continuer avec le
discours moralisant le discours pseudo
libéral qu'on entend régulièrement la
part des diplomaties occidentales et la
réalité maintenant vous a éclaté en
plein visage parce qu'on s'en rend
compte que les pays occidentaux
s'associer à des états qui pratiquent
des politiques violente agressive et
meurtrière et c'est là où on voit cette
contradiction que vous vous êtes vous
confronté du doigt avec beaucoup de
justesse entre le discours et la
pratique
le discours est généreux basé sur des
mets étaient de grands principes très
très près valable mais mais pas plus et
la réalité c'est une relation de rapport
de force
le rapport de force et la volonté
d'établir une domination de la région
en s'associant aux pays qui sont prêts à
jouer ce jeu là notamment
l'arabie saoudite et graal les trois là
sont les associés d'aujourd'hui qui
essaie de mettre en place un système de
contrôle de la région dirigée contre
lyon écartant la turquie est
naturellement rencontre contre offensive
mais c'est seulement je voulais aussi
continuer sur le meurtre du jeune
insurgé
est-ce que vous pensez que que à cause
de ça est ce qu'il y aura des aces qui
aura des conséquences sur le poids et
l'influencé allemande dont le royaume
parce qu'on a vu que que récemment son
père est il là il a un peu mis sur la
commission denquête est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il va vraiment son influence va
continuer à grandir ou bien le meurtre
va un peu changer les cartes et à
l'intérieur du royaume c'est la même
question que j'allais pouces c'est parti
donc on est sur la même longueur d'onde
c'est une excellente question parce que
elle nous oblige à regarder vers
l'avenir
est-ce que nds pourra tenir c'est
possible comme il est possible qu'ils
soient sacrifiés afin de continuer la
politique actuelle parce que du côté des
pneus et des pays occidentaux notamment
les états unis avec leurs alliés radiant
leur problème aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
qu'à souris ou le meurtre de sa satiété
complètement secondaire leur problème
c'est le fait que l'ap que cette cette
crise oblige l'arabie saoudite a changé
politique ou la rendant difficile la
constitution de cette alliance anti
aériennes iraniennes à la l'obstacle
apparaît comme étant le prince eric et
il n'est pas impossible qu'ils soient
sacrifiés afin de continuer la même
politique c'est pas possible pour le
moment ce n'est pas encore le cas
ils le soutiennent en espérant que il
pourra traverser la tempête
mais la tempête peut être aggravée par
la turquie la tasse riz joue un jeu très
important ici elle dispute
quotidiennement des informations qui
mettent à mal les explications de l'est
pas par iad
il arrive avec de nouvelles révélations
comme la question du club où est le
corps de tori s'ils reviennent avec les
questions là qui met à mal la bio dit il
mais pas impossible que le roi d'arabie
saoudite etc et des partenaires
occidentaux trifi ou l'inde
le prince héritier afin de continuer la
même politique parce que ce qui compte
pour eux ce n'est pas le pratiquer c'est
la politique de l'ulster stratégie
géopolitique dans la joue à voir
l'alliance contre au complet en dernière
question messieurs sol on a commencé
l'émission en parlant de liberté
d'expression liberté de presse
et puis j'aimerais que vous nous fassiez
une description sur ce journaliste on
parle de lui partout mais je sais qu'il
était en premier très proche pendant
beaucoup d'années très proche du régime
saoudien puis finalement il ya fait
dissidence
et puis maintenant il est décédé donc
parlez nous de ce journaliste comment on
pourrait le décrire ses personnages
c'était un peu connu mais un homme du
sérail
ce n'est pas un contestataire de la base
n'est pas quelqu'un qui issu du peuple
qui contestent le régime
c'est un membre du de l'élite d'un
membre de l'ue groupe blue qui gouverne
à l'arabie saoudite qui était le le le
le partenaire de de l'ambassadeur
saoudien en aux états unis qui est le
neveu d'un grand marchand d'armes son
oncle adnan khashoggi était un grand
marchand d'armes des années 80
richissime financier donc a fait
beaucoup de beaucoup d'argent et on a
affaire donc un journaliste qui n'est
pas acquis fait partie de
l'establishment noms proches du pouvoir
mais il arrive un moment est arrivé au
moment où chiite au printemps suite à
2,1 2011 où il a semblé vouloir aller
dans le sens de 2,2 de la côte d'une de
la soirée fort de changer les pratiques
changer un peu les méthodes du régime et
s'est approchée surtout des frères
musulmans alors ça c'est la ligne à ne
pas franchir pour les wahhabites qui
dirige l'arabie saoudite des frères
musulmans sont des ennemis mortels sont
des ennemis aux fins de l'islamisme est
facho qui a épousé la cause des frères
mes jeux
il a aussi ici aussi associé au courant
américain qui conteste trappe saisir les
frères musulmans sont les laits le les
préférés du courant clinton obama qui
voulait justement des changements à la
rentrée à l'intérieur d'arabie saoudite
et la mise en place ou l'arrivée au
pouvoir peut-être des frères musulmans
alors kobe est associée à ce courant là
et il est contre le courant trempe de sa
quête qui lui est et d'un protecteur un
parent du prince est du prince héritier
alors on a affaire ici un luttes de
pouvoir au sein de l'arabie saoudite et
luttes de pouvoir au sein des états unis
sur entre les courants propre et clinton
et entre en arabie saoudite entre le
wahhabisme et les frères musulmans et
khashoggi et et est un instrument ou une
sorte de d'acteur dans cette
dans cette bataille mais c'est un homme
de pouvoir c'est quelqu'un qui était
parti du de délits des agentes et pas
c'est pas un contestataire et la
réplique qui portaient les gardes arabie
saoudite et un critique tout à fait
modérées ne demandez pas là en
versements du régime
les apps le manque est quelqu'un qui est
qu'il fallait faire quelques
aménagements quelle que forme non il a
prouvé nombre de politiques du régime
par exemple la guerre au yémen
il la trouve l'intervention d'arabie
saoudite en syrie
il l'a prouvé donc ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui qui était véritablement
une radicale c'est quelqu'un qui vous
avez quelques aménagements afin de
sauver l'arabie saoudite et c'est donc
au sein de l'élite que cette bataille se
joue monsieur samir sol vous nous avez
donné jusqu'à inscrire 100 à beaucoup
d'entre nous là quand vous avez parlé
des liens qui entre les familles clinton
trump et puis les manger serbe moi j'ai
plus à nulle part peut-être vous étiez
au courant sa mère vous qui est plus
familier avec eux c'est bien d'avoir
apporté toutes ces questions c'est grâce
aux couacs au qatar quand on est arrivés
sur le terrain merci beaucoup monsieur
soldes avoir accepté l'invitation
aujourd'hui nous avons apporté vos
connaissances par rapport à tout ça fait
plaisir
alors c'est s est mis au sol qui est
spécialiste des questions du moyen
orient à l'université de montréal
alors écoutez
le supplice de la goutte c'est ce que je
devais retenir aussi et puis on dit idi
qui va être sacrifiée peut-être sur poté
soit il s'agit de demander ce qui va
être sacrifié comme d'autres princes
ces dernières années qui ont été tués en
arabie saoudite des princes pour faire
donner l'exemple
je vous avais pas eu de signal
le roi khaled a été a été assassiné à la
fin de ce sans raison que c'est des
choses qui se produisent ce qui se fait
à la manière des accidents qui arrivent
comme ça par hasard aussi résistante
voiture préférée celle ci dans l'avion
mais on peut sacrifier l'autrement ok on
a des spécialistes sud autour de la
table j'en suis seul à la fois ailleurs
jaune
oui tu as gagné aujourd'hui il ya eu 50
points accordés à la reine il ya eu 66
cabanier sans fausse note
victoire difficile mais ressent quand il
disait il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
par lee quane ne pas être n'ont ils
comprendraient pas qu'ils viennent de
bois moi ce que j'ai juste une remarque
à faire c'était vraiment intéressant ce
qu'a dit mais de voir qu'un journaliste
soit associée à un courant ça nous nous
ici on n'a pas ça en public
alors je les ai vus parler de ça il ya
deux jours de cela il ya une vidéo sur
le village oublié on lui disait
journaliste doit être neutre il a dit
mais écoutez en 2011 tu ne pouvais plus
être notre histoire les propositions qui
aillent habiter la journée à faire
remarquer ça il avait répondu je dirais
je devais je devais prendre être du côté
du bon côté de l'histoire si tu veux un
même temps c'est à dire on n'a pas à
accepter un courant une manière de faim
ou une autre où je ne crois pas qu'on
doit faire c'est pourquoi mais c'est
qu'à saugy a senti ce besoin de
s'aligner combien il y avait dans le
printemps arabe devrait pas le faire
malheureusement au journalisme tout le
temps mais on y arrive il faut
comprendre je vais pas de la sphère de
l'existence de des armes de destruction
massive en irak où vous vous souvenez de
cette journaliste de 12,8 millions
vous l'avez oublié c'est une journaliste
américaine très très influente qui a été
justement sous l'influencé de la maison
blanche qui a été la première à écrire
sur cette affaire elle était parmi les
premiers journalistes à mentionner
l'existence des armes de destruction
massive en irak ce qui a motivé cette
guerre là cette guerre qui a été
vivement critiquée mais elle s'est
rétractée par la suite
oui mais là pas elle n'a pas été sous
l'influencé est cité la maison blanche
qui lui donnait des sceaux pour
influencer pour ses clients mais pas
d'émissions obligé de quitter le
journalisme parce qu'elle a menti au
monde entier l'information qu'elle a
diffusée a été reprise en boucle par la
plupart des médias aujourd'hui si on
m'en si on est associés on le voit sur
la neutralité j'en animé par gilles fau
rendre le contexte c'est des pays qui ne
connaissait pas la démocratie y avait
une petite ouverture de démocratie lui à
l'epo selon ce qu'ils disent est ce que
vraiment ça dépasse un peu un traité on
n'est pas dans un système où par exemple
ici au canada
la démocratie elle est là donc on ne
peut pas se prendre position pour l'un
ou l'autre mais elle est à construire
donc lui il est allé du côté de la
démocratie suis pas en train de le
défendre mais un peu de comprendre
comment il avait ouvert la fenêtre il ne
restait plus beaucoup il reste une
minute à notre net
moi je vous préviens de suite le seul
courant auquel je suis associé c'est un
courant d'air chaud
conclusion avec l'hiver mal servi et
petits que les journalistes devraient
travailler à rester neutre et je sens
qu'un froid ici entre nous deux mais on
a tous décidé à lyon aulas tous
l'opinion c'est vrai mais je travaille
ce n est pas d parce qu'il faut revenir
à ce que les premiers journalistes qui
ont 30 secondes à ce qu'ils étaient et
ce qu'ils étaient la semaine prochaine
oui oui ça m a dit tu es journal
[Rires]